since late April myself and machine
learning engineer Josh Stapleton have
evaluated over a hundred and twenty
thousand answers from GPT models to
explore their limits in my original
smart GPT video I showed that even
popular TED Talks calling gpt4 stupid
were not accurately testing what gpt4
could do and actually it could easily
get such questions right little did we
foresee that come the summer our tests
with Gypsy 4 would be revealing a host
of mistakes in an official globally used
Benchmark uncovering concerns that even
open Ai and Google don't appear to be
aware of but by the end of the video I
want to show how you can tangibly
benefit from our experiments including
in unexpected domains like medicine
where to start well here's a super quick
intro to those of you who haven't seen
the original video smartgbt was a way of
using the latest prompt engineering
research to trigger better performance
in a model like GP E4 getting the model
to think a bit AKA use some tokens
before giving a final answer was key
another important element I talked about
in that video was the power of getting
the model to self-reflect an Insight I
drew on from talks with the lead author
of the famous reflection paper my manual
experiments showed that using optimized
prompts reflection and self-dialogue you
could boost performance in almost any
task and I demoed the Improvement on
formal logic and college mathematics but
there was a problem which is why you
guys haven't heard about smartgbt in a
while how could I systematically
Benchmark gc4 using these methods when
I'm just one guy well enter Josh
Stapleton machine learning engineer
extraordinaire without him it would have
been impossible to build out such a
fleshed out flexible code base with
which we could systematize experiments
and iterate rapidly but then we both
quickly realized that there was another
problem with benchmarking the original
version of smartgbt on tens of thousands
of official questions it would be hell
to manually extract out the final
answers within pages of reflection and
resolving not to mention cost tens of
thousands of dollars and trust me a
month of YouTube advertising would not
even cover the first hour of that run
unfortunately and no we would never
compromise by asking gpt4 to grade its
own answers it would be unscientific and
inaccurate the infamous Mit paper is
enough evidence of that gpt4 didn't get
100 on an MIT degree and this paper was
withdrawn so yes we had to lower the
power level of smart GPT get rid of the
reflection and resolving deliberately
sacrificing some of its intelligence
because we simply couldn't afford to
unleash it fully and yet we still got a
new albeit unofficial record of 88.4 on
the mmlu that not only beats the 86.4
recorded by open AI it beats the
projections for 2024 the metaculus
recorded before TPT came out and yet we
are both convinced that there are at
least a dozen more ways performance can
be further boosted using existing models
yes that might mean gpt4 getting a
result reserved for June of 2025. the
thing is we have hit the limits of what
a self-funding team of two can do before
I briefly touch on what the mmlu is I am
happy to say that all of our results and
answers that's 2850 for the gp4 run and
over 120
000 for GPT 3.5 are freely available to
browse in a GitHub repository Linked In
the description so what the hell is mmlu
anyway well it is arguably the best
known Benchmark of language model
performance it stands for massive
multitask language understanding massive
because it has over 14 000 questions and
multitask because it covers 57 different
domains the idea behind it was truly
fantastic and it is important enough to
feature prominently on the first page of
the gpt4 technical report in the past I
have said that getting a hundred percent
on this test would be a good sign of AGI
others have talked about 95 I do think I
have like a 50 chance like within the
next 20 years or so there might be
something will be my call in HEI or a
transformative AI what do I mean by this
well so maybe can measure it on
benchmarks there's like this famous mmlu
benchmarks like yeah there's something
which like scores like 95 on this and
the paper itself notes that an 89.8
performance represents human expert
ability which as you can tell from the
title we are achingly close to beating
and as you'll see in a moment gpt4 with
the full power of prompt engineering
could likely get upwards of 90 to 92
right now and frankly whether it's gpd5
or Gemini that 95 threshold should
easily be broken by next year not in 20
years if we didn't use the full power of
smart GPT how did we get 88.4 and why
does the title say 89 well let me show
you the two facets of smart GPT that we
did use the thing is the mmlu demands A
Single Character answer A B C or D and
that answer must be immediate now
imagine taking a test and the very first
thought you had ad had to be your final
answer on a quick tangent this is
believed to be a key reason for
hallucinations this was a great paper on
how language model hallucinations can
snowball from the first few tokens as
they say the language model first
commits to an answer that's before
outputting the explanation and this is a
problem because Transformers cannot find
the answer within one time step because
of their limited reasoning abilities
within that times that and why don't
language models like gpt4 back down and
change halfway through well they
prioritize fluency and coherence at the
expense of factuality but rushing an
answer in your first token is
particularly hobbling in questions like
this requiring deeper thought or
calculation it's fine for questions that
need memorized knowledge but not for
questions like these we went through all
of these subjects in the mmlu and
characterized around a third of them as
requiring that kind of deeper thought
and of course most ways that you use
gpd4 will also require some thought but
I'll touch more on practical uses at the
end open source teams and groups like
openai and Google all draw on the devset
when testing a model notice the five
questions each with a single character
answer we were not of course the first
team to realize that this underplays the
abilities of the model the Minerva paper
from Google said this the standard way
of evaluating on the mmlu is to
construct a five shot prompt out of the
dev set so what they did instead like us
was to use a prompt which has a Chain of
Thought before outputting the final
answer you can see some examples below
essentially it allows the model to think
a bit first and gives it a scratch Pad
there were other theories though like
the length and detail of the exemplars
triggering different weights of the
model this paper from two months ago
used longer exemplars for the moral
scenario subject within the mmlu with
these five custom them exemplars plus
self-consistency which I'll get to in a
moment they saw accuracy go up to 80
from 68 but before even this paper came
out Josh and I were sourcing and
crafting bespoke exemplars or the 21
subjects we deemed would need the most
working out but the other subjects we
may do with the normal Dev examples
openai and Google don't do this for
their benchmarking underplaying the
abilities of their model so why doesn't
everyone do it you might ask my theory
is that it's because you have to hand
grade every answer rather than just
lazily check for an exact character
match through Auto grading essentially
you're taking the time to listen which
is the least that we can do I feel as we
approach human level intelligences even
though it still took weeks to make
checking easier we taught GPT 3.5 and
gpd4 through our exemplars to always end
with a final answer in the same format
lesson one therefore for everyone
watching is don't make the first token
the final answer for the question you
ask lesson two comes from a paper on
self-consistency which in a nutshell
says that taking the highest probability
answer sometimes called greedy decoding
doesn't always reflect the best answer
the model is capable of in other words
don't take the model's first answer as
its final answer take this example the
highest single probability answer was
this and that was incorrect for open AI
it would now be over it's incorrect done
but sometimes if you look at all the
different answers that a model might
give and then take the majority answer
the final answer that came up the most
often it can get it right interestingly
in the Minerva paper they used
256 samples although only 16 for the
mmlu openai even put a little footnote
in their gpt4 technical paper admitting
that they don't use that approach but
Google does and yes this can
significantly affect the final results
look at the Boost going up to 40
sampling paths and it hasn't fully
leveled off yet these aren't redos where
you keep trying until you get it right
this is letting the model explore its
full probability distribution of outputs
and taking the truly most probable Final
Answer letting the model think not
rushing it for our runs we limited
ourselves to nine samples and took the
majority vote but of course the results
could have been dramatically better if
we did 40 samples or indeed 256. now
aside from these two hard-won lessons
which I'm going to show how all of you
can benefit from the other difference
from the previous state-of-the-art 86.4
was that we did use the most current
versions of each model so the models may
have independently gotten better or
worse in certain topics but I would say
that our broad findings do run counter
to any simple it's got Dumber narrative
and if I had to guess behind the scenes
open AI have implemented some fine
tuning involving step-by-step Solutions
as I see that phrase cropping up in
answers where it didn't used to and that
particular trick from the original
smartgbt seems less effective than
before I'm now going to ask Josh to talk
about our state of the art score not
only with gpt4 but also with GPT 3.5 but
just before I do here is a hint of why
the title talks about breaking a
benchmark I'll show you how gpt4 itself
encouraged us to question many of the
answers in the mmlu starting with one
strange answer and then like pulling on
a thread leading to the discovery of at
least 80 and likely hundreds of errors
in the test enough to significantly
affect final results by up to two
percent and given that the differences
in say the open source language model
leaderboard come down to as little as
0.1 of a percent that's pretty big yes
we've been in contact with some of the
authors of the test over the past month
to check our findings and I'll say more
in a bit but first here is ml engineer
Josh detailing how the magic happened
Josh by the way is a precocious AI
consultant working on a masters at
Imperial College London hi everyone nice
to meet you all my name is Josh
Stapleton and let me show you the
version of smart GPT we used the smart
GPT framework is highly parallelized and
can handle industry scale use cases we
used a thread and a sync i o based
approach to make simultaneous calls to
the API at answer option answer and
subject levels stacking parallelization
upon parallelization this led to Crazy
iteration speed boosts for example we
were able to complete the final gbt4 run
in under two hours generating single
answer options in series would have
taken weeks we did two large runs using
smart GPT first with GPT 3.5 and then
gpt4 the 3.5 run was on the entirety of
mmlu for a total of 9 times
14042 questions 126
000 answers this was a mammoth effort to
manually grade but the smart GPT
innovation and hard work ended up
boosting GPT 3.5's performance by a
significant 3.7 percent from 70 to 73.7
percent the gbt4 Run using smart GPT
also beat the open AI mmru Benchmark
score substantially and this run
actually resulted in the discovery of a
number of problematic mmlu questions
which Philip will talk about shortly the
cost to run gpt4 on all mmru would have
been too high for us to self-fund having
already each invested four figure sums
so we used a representative subset of
2850 questions from the total of 14042
of course fully weighted two official
standards smart GPT is a model agnostic
parametrized and highly flexible system
that can be applied to disparate use
cases we are already working on
applications in a number of domains in
both the public and private sectors the
system is evolving and improving
constantly under the hood as we continue
to innovate while the current system can
get state-of-the-art results with the
ability to handle Enterprise scale data
there are a number of known ways to
improve it which we aim to implement in
the near future from better and more
numerous automatically sourced exemplars
to llm driven prompt optimization to
fine-tuning we are just getting started
with smart GPT and we are uniquely
positioned as a tiny team to integrate
both our own ongoing improvements as
well as promising discoveries in the
field as they arise back to Philip thank
you Josh I will be working with you well
at least until you're snapped up by a
giant AI org anyway back to Breaking the
Benchmark here is the question that
started it all off as you can see the
question makes no sense the text says
demand reduction and the answers are
either one three four two three four one
two three one two four what on Earth is
that about now remember it was only
human grading that enabled us to spot
this I reckon most companies like openai
rely on auto grading by exact match that
would immediately toss out any answer
like these as no all because an answer
of A B C or D hasn't been given now I
should say it was human grading that
caught this and gpt4 itself here is poor
GPT 3.5 bravely giving an answer to a
question that doesn't make absolutely
any sense at all I love how a couple of
times it changed its mind and was like
no no D not B what Then followed was
weeks and weeks of me following up every
quote-unquote mistake with the official
Source the question came from when I
found the original Source I realized
what the problem was sometimes they just
hadn't pasted all of these statements
when you can see all four of these
statements the answer options make a lot
more sense now I know what some of you
may be thinking maybe it's just business
ethics that's just one subject and what
it's a dozen questions what's the big
deal well first of all business ethics
only has 100 questions so 13 of them
missing vital context completely
undermines that entire subject and
second of all it wasn't just business
ethics and it wasn't just this same
problem it wouldn't always be about
missing statements check out these
examples from high school chemistry and
there's High School psychology
Professional Psychology microeconomics
professional law professional accounting
and trust me it didn't stop there I was
genuinely shocked there were innumerable
factual errors and I would try to trace
down the origin of each and see what the
source said by the way the problem
wasn't just with one source it was with
quite a few of these sources let a
random take one of these questions how
many human polyoma viruses are known at
present 101 10 or unknown this question
comes from Oxford University press
chapter 21 question two I researched the
question myself and also checked what
this multiple choice quiz said the
answer was let's tick 10 which is answer
C and then submit my answers to the quiz
and let's see yes it's correct it's 10.
by the way the actual answer seems to be
14 as of 2023 but that's fairly close
what does the mmlu say it's says the
answer is a 100 and it goes on and on
like this some of the worst offenders
are the virology and college chemistry
sections just wrong answer after wrong
answer after wrong answer here's another
example this is what the mmlu says is
the answer to this question B I track
down the question to a fall of 2011
final exam in which the answer was B the
mmlu had mixed up the order of the
options and therefore picked B when that
was drug users instead of men but
there's one more slight problem research
suggests that both of those answers are
inaccurate and that happened multiple
times where even the source was somewhat
dodgy with its answers here is another
page of mistakes of virology and another
page for college chemistry and one
example that will particularly shock AI
researchers here we have a question for
which the mmlu says the correct answer
is a the original Source says that the
answer is eight which isn't even an
option but this question was in the
devset and if you remember from earlier
in the video that is the set of five
questions they used to teach the model
what kind of answer to give when they're
benchmarking in the mmlu in other words
all 100 results in college chemistry for
every model benched on the mmlu is
compromised for example a model that is
particularly good at imitating reasoning
will now be imitating an incorrect
answer now you might be thinking surely
now Philip and gpt4 are done with
finding errors in the mmlu unfortunately
not we carry on into new categories here
is a question from econometrics where
again the source was incorrect but we
also have misspellings grammatical
ambiguity and formatting ambiguity
throughout the test I'm not going to go
through all of these but any one of them
could potentially confuse a model we
already know that models are very
sensitive to the inputs you give are
there any more categories yes there are
there are loads of Juicy examples here
but I can't get to them all how about
example of multi-question dependents for
example this came up in the philosophy
section according to singer compliance
with his principle requires but of
course it doesn't say which of his
principles or this one singer's argument
begins with the assumption that now if
you look at the original question it
gave the context of the arguments it
talked about the arguments and
principles from his book famine
affluence and morality but in the mmlu
there is no such context and again and
again this comes up high school bio you
can see the two examples here now there
is one final category I want to talk
about no clear answer I'm not going to
categorically call this a mistake but
what answer would you pick here this is
in public relations when an attitude is
communicated what does it become an
opinion A belief a behavior a point of
view I think that's pretty ambiguous
those kind of questions were
particularly prevalent in moral
scenarios and public relations or how
about this are cryptocurrencies
expensive or cheap is there an easy
answer to that and there was one
question that I did about three hours of
research for what is the biggest cause
of death in children under five years
old and there are multiple sources that
give conflicting answers that type of
question where it depends what source
you ask was massively prevalent in the
global facts category and then we get
controversial questions like this in
security studies how do biological
differences affect the roles that men
and women must perform for the state
with the correct answer being gender
roles are a social construct I feel GPT
4's answer is far more nuanced this
question touches on complex and
controversial topics and while there is
evidence to support or a few elements
within each of the provided statements
none of them fully captures the nuanced
relationship between biology gender
roles society and state responsibilities
it also picks up on that language must
perform for the state now remember these
are just the examples that I found on a
subset of the full test extrapolated out
that would suggest that hundreds of
questions are ambiguous or erroneous now
a one two or three percent inaccuracy
rate didn't really matter when models
were performing at around 25 or 30
percent that's close to random and that
was GPT 3's original performance but now
when we're talking about AGI or human
expert level accuracy and models are
being judged on tenths of a percent one
two or three percent really makes a big
difference that's why the title says 89
because if you just remove the clear
mistakes that I found of the valid
questions our final result was 89.0 that
number is of course more tentative as
there may have been mistakes that both
the test and gpt4 made that missed our
scrupulous checks so at the moment we
have a disparate set of benchmarks of
varying degrees of validity and yes I've
already begun to research some of the
other benchmarks hello swag also appears
to suffer from the first character
equals Final Answer issue and honestly
reviewing some of the questions I am
more than tempted to order gpt4's
mistakes on that Benchmark next of
course I've been following attempts
released very recently to develop
cutting-edge benchmarks like legal bench
and side bench they both look very
promising I have even personally taught
some of the topics that appear in other
benchmarks like Aqua rat and AGI eval
and let's not even get into Helm and
other Suites of benchmarks that accept
different formats of answer making
comparisons confusing for Outsiders and
even insiders I feel that the case is
now strong for an independent
professional benchmarking organization
to be asked to step in perhaps one of
the major education companies like
Pearson funded by the top AGI Labs
inspired by the Fantastic Vision behind
the mmlu they could design an incredibly
broad range of subject tests and those
could be rolled into a benchmark that
stretched all the way to extreme
difficulties I've got more ideas on that
maybe for another video each question
could be rigorously vetted to be
unambiguous and the volume and diversity
of questions would reduce the kind of
overfitting that people are worrying
about now with human eval and of course
the answers could also be blind human
graded all models including open source
ones held to the exact same standard and
given the best chance to shine we need
to Benchmark these models to the best of
their abilities find the ceiling of what
they can do not the floor as Paul
Cristiano formerly of open AI has
recently stated a broad understanding of
AI capabilities and how these
capabilities are likely to change over
time would significantly reduce risks
and I believe that there should be
additional practical components to these
benchmarks like questions on managing
equipment in a bio lab as Dario amade of
anthropic has speculated will soon be
highly relevant and I would love to see
modules designed by departments within
AGI Labs made to detect how close AI is
getting to being able to automate its
own creation just this morning from
semi-analysis we learned that Google
Gemini is set to draw on five times the
compute of gpd4 making these kind of
benchmarks more urgent than ever so when
Gemini gbt5 and Claude 3 come out we
deserve to know the absolute limit of
their ability rather than have that be
discovered in the wild as openai's gpt4
technical report warned about but as
promised to all of those who've come
this far you deserve to see an example
of how you can use all of this in the
here and now to improve performance
whether you're a multinational or an
individual who's just curious look at
this official medical diagnosis question
of the type that an NHS doctor here in
the UK would have to think through look
what happens if you give no exemplars no
real time to think and just take the
first answer obviously not many of you
are going to be Medical but this is a
plausible diagnosis just not the most
likely one it is definitively the
incorrect answer in the NHS textbook but
maybe that's just the one-off you're
thinking nope I tried eight times I
think every time from memory it gave
that answer SLE or lupus which is
incorrect let's see that's the third
time if you can read these if you like
but pretty much every time it's saying
SLE and here is number eight Yes again
SLE according to a professional medical
opinion that I sought out gpt4 has
picked up on some of the details but not
on others it didn't pick up on the
nodular appearance of the rash or the
fact that it's on the forehead now let's
give it some exemplars the more the
merrier as you can see they're not
directly related to the question but
they help the model or wait do they this
answer is again SLE but don't forget
self-consistency those exemplars do help
but you need to give the model time next
time with the exact same prompt I got
the answer sarcoidosis which is correct
then SLE then sarcoidosis and this time
sarcoidosis but for the final example
I'm going to draw on the full power of
smart GPT I'm going to get gpt4 to
reflect on its answers obviously we
couldn't do that for the full mmlu but
we can do it here I plugged in the two
diagnoses both of those came from gpd4
and then I asked it to reflect which of
these explanations is the most
convincing based on the evidence
supplied and this time the full smart
GPT kicked in answer one was sarcoidosis
as was answer two and
answer three and you get the picture
answer four and finally answer five
Isn't that cool we went from always
getting it wrong with no exemplars and
no self-consistency to always getting it
right with exemplars self-consistency
and self-reflection obviously I am not
saying that you should rely on gpd4 for
medical diagnoses but I am saying that
you might be surprised about the
diversity of domains to which such
methods can be applied and no such
methods won't guarantee success after
all we didn't get a hundred percent but
it does push models closer to their
limit and we are constantly reading the
latest papers to further push
performance whether it's skeleton of
thoughts tree of thoughts graph of
thoughts or thought experiments man that
is a lot of thoughts so let us know if
you've enjoyed this Mammoth ongoing
effort or learn something from it and as
ever thanks for watching to the end and
have a wonderful day